Fillings may soon be a thing of the past!
Thank goodness cuz the only kind of filling
I need in my life is the kind that goes in
pie.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
Cavities have got to be one of the worst parts
of being a human.
I've only had one filling in my life when
I was like 12 and I'm still mildly traumatized.
But thank goodness -- fillings may be a thing
of the past in as soon as 3 years!
What a time to be alive!
Researchers at King's College London have
created a device that can fix cavities by
spurring teeth to repair themselves instead.
The current procedure for treating tooth decay
is based on some pretty primitive stuff actually
-- it's basically the same today as the original
procedure discovered in 1875.
The tooth decay is drilled out and then the
hole is filled back up.
Back in the day, the hole in your tooth was
filled with silver, but now they're filled
with amalgam or resin.
The new procedure is called Electrically Accelerated
and Enhanced Remineralization, and it basically
sidesteps the drilling and filling phases
altogether by using an electrical current
that remineralizes the tooth.
There are two steps.
First, the surface of the tooth is prepared,
and then the device delivers an electric current
that forces minerals like calcium and phosphate
into the tooth.
This effectively rebuilds the tooth -- which
makes the tooth even stronger and naturally
repairs the cavity.
The scientists say that the electrical current
used is gentle -- so gentle, in fact, that
you can't even feel it.
I meeeaaann.....this sounds like a dream come
true does it not?
As an added bonus, the cost of the procedure
will likely be about the same price or cheaper
than current tooth decay treatments.
AND, the device can even whiten teeth.
SIGN.
ME.
UP!
The only known drawbacks to note are that
the device can't repair cavities which have
progressed too far -- so you'll still want
to stay on top of your dental appointments.
The scientists also noted that the device
can't actually physically regrow a new tooth
so....you're out of luck on that one.
I'm super excited for this thing to get rolling
-- about 35% of the world's population deals
with untreated tooth decay.
It's a problem that only been exaggerated
in recent decades by the increasing availability
of sugary foods.
So basically: this thing could literally change
the world!
Are you ready for it?
Let me know what you think about this new
device down below.
Thanks for joining me for Dnews everyone!
Don't forget to subscribe for more science
updates.